hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
powering multi onic translational
studies with mass cytometry
characterizing the molecular pacemakers
of pregnancy presented by dr. brief
Saudi Air an assistant professor
standard University School of Medicine
department of anesthesiology in dr. Nima
Ejiofor assistant professor and standard
University School of Medicine
I'm Christina Jolin laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by fluid I'm for more
information about our sponsor please
visit fluid I'm calm now before we begin
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen have your
questions into the box and click send
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also view trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or you can report
your problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on far left of your
screen I would now like to introduce our
two presenters beginning with dr. briefs
zodiac born in France dr. Gutierrez
studied engineering at Ecole
Polytechnique before completing an MD
ph.d degree from the Harvard MIT Health
Sciences and Technology program during
his postdoctoral fellowship in Gary
Nolan's laboratory Stanford University
dr. Cody are developed and standardized
a pipeline to implement high dimensional
math cytometry vomit rebuy time of
flight mass spectometry the basis of the
site hop system in clinical studies our
second presenter will be dr. NEMA idea
for the Graduate research at the
University of British Columbia focused
on bioinformatics analysis of single
cell data together with colleagues at
the National Institute of Health they
established the first objective
benchmark for evaluation of algorithms
that could automatically identify cell
types and eventually correlate them with
clinical outcomes namely the flow flow
cytometry critical
assessment of population identification
methods low-pass as a postdoc with Gary
Nolan at Stanford and now an independent
faculty member he's been interested in
the intersection of data sciences
immunology and a clinical phenotype
being an alumni of the standard Graduate
School of Business ignite program NEMA
also regularly consults for a wide range
of companies on both technology
development and data analysis please
join me in welcoming dr. briefs Gautier
and dr. Nima idea for I will now turn
the presentation over to our speakers
filmin welcome to both of you
I thank you very much for the
introduction it's a pleasure to be here
and have the opportunity to present our
work integrating mass atomic tree with
other omics platform to characterize the
molecular based makers of pregnancy as
you heard in the introduction
Nia and I were both postdocs in Gary
Nolan's lab and we started working on
projects together there and since then
we've been collaborating on multiple
research projects so we thought it'd be
fun to give it joint presentation sorry
very generally our research uses a deep
immune profiling of clinical samples
with mass spectrometry and combines this
with high dimensional modeling
approaches to understand how the human
immune system adapts to physiological
perturbations or physiological stressors
now examples we draw examples of these
physiological stressors from clinical
studies and clinical scenarios we're
very interested in trauma traumatic
injury our model is major surgery
surgical trauma and we're interested
here in understanding the human immune
response to traumatic injury and
identifying phenological events that
predict the recovery of patients from
pain and disability after surgery we use
a very similar approach in the in the
context of ischemic brain injury or
acute stroke and here we're
understanding we're trying to understand
what are the components of the immune
response to occurs
that may be predictive of neurocognitive
recovery in patients but today the focus
of this talk is going to be on our work
on pregnancy four years ago we had we
started a very fascinating collaboration
with a March of Dimes Center for
prematurity research at Stanford led by
dr. Stevenson and our goal within the
center is to understand the normal
immune response to pregnancy with the
aim to identify immunological
abnormalities that are associated with
preterm births of prematurity preterm
birth being the number one cause of
neonatal mortality in the world now
importantly all of these projects are
done in close collaboration with Martin
X who is a professor of anesthesiology
here at Stanford
so why pregnancy well pregnancy is a
fascinating in illogical phenomenon the
the maintenance of pregnancy relies on a
finely tuned immune balance between
immune tolerance to the Hemme allergenic
fetus so for example a factory cd4 T
cells and cd8 t-cell are excluded from
the placenta in the decidua particularly
so that they can't even reach or
interact easily with fetal antigens
there's also very important expansion of
peripheral T rights that are fetal
antigen specific that's from the world
by sensing way that we know is extremely
important in the maintenance of
pregnancy now these immune tolerance
mechanisms have to be balanced with
protective immunity against infectious
pathogens and so there's also an
exacerbated and exacerbated response
from innate immune cells during
pregnancy and what's really interesting
is that this immune balance lasts
exactly nine months after 40 weeks there
perhaps there is perhaps an
immunological switch that happens that
allows the changes 200 go and lead to
the birth of the fetus that you can
think about as almost a rejection of the
fetus from the uterus and so
the timing of these immunological
responses during pregnancy is very
important and this is the large major
focus of the study that we started here
the goal again was to understand what is
the timing of normal immunological
adaptations to a turn pregnancy focusing
on maternal immunizations and with the
the idea that if we understand normal we
can set up the analytical framework to
then be able to identify this functional
responses or or disrupted at the
disrupted timing of these immunological
adaptations in pathology pathological
pregnancies like preterm birth or
preeclampsia so the first part of this
of this presentation is really gonna
focus on our analysis of peripheral
immune cell responses in maternal blood
and then NEMA will tell us about the
most recent and exciting work to
integrate this analysis with other omics
platform that allows us to characterize
other base makers of pregnancy so how do
we do this well we use math cytometry or
side-valve which as you know is a high
parameter of flow cytometry technology
that uses anybodies conjugated to metal
isotopes rather than fluorophores and by
leveraging the dynamic range and the
lack of spectral overlap of mass
spectrometry we the technology allows
for the simultaneous measurement of over
50 parameters per single immune cell
present in blood sample now it's
important to remember that half of these
parameters about half of these
parameters in a typical typical set off
panel will be composed of anybody's that
recognize phenotypic markers for example
surface epitopes epitopes that allow us
to distinguish in different immune cells
and precisely phenotype these immune
cells and then at the same time we can
use another twenty parameters to us to
assess the activity of interest errors
pathways for example looking at the
phosphorylation form of various
signaling proteins or the intracellular
expression of cytokines and that tells
us something about the function of these
immune cells now in order to visualize
the sorry the high parameter my
cytometry data set there are several
algorithm that are applicable that are
that are there that exist that all use
more or less the same idea to cluster
using the phenotypic markers to cluster
various in the different immune cells
based on their phenotype and allows us
to to build the maps or comprehensive
maps of the immune system so now there's
Spade
there's citrus Disney vortex one of the
last clustering algorithm that came out
and here I'm showing you an example from
a study that was published a couple
years ago where we used in collaboration
with Matt Spitzer and Federico
giardiniera in the Noland lab we use a
fourth directed layout to represent on
the same structure the peripheral immune
system from the mother and from the
fetus comparing peripheral blood from
the mother and humble cord from the
mother at birth and what we can do is
not only overlay the the phenotypic
landscape of these these two systems but
also the functional landscape and from
his study we could learn a lot of other
similarities and differences between the
mature immune system of the mother and
the developing immune system of the
fetus at birth we also used a different
approach
a similar approach in the context of
preterm birth and that was our first
pilot study in this in this respect when
we compared the baseline logical state
of women that are not pregnant but at
high risk of delivering preterm in their
next pregnancy so we compared women that
had a history of term pregnancy was
women that had a history of repeated
preterm pregnancy
a similar mass spectometry approach to
comprehensively characterize immune cell
responses in this baseline state and
using saturate site citrus were able to
identify components of this immune
system that were associated with this
risk of preterm birth and notably what
we found was that in the myeloid cell
compartment mostly dendritic cells and
classical monocytes had an exacerbated
response to the tr4 agonist LPS in women
with a history of preterm births so now
the study that we're gonna be focusing
on for this talk continues with this
with these application of my cytometry
but here the question is from the
measurement of peripheral immune cell
response in the mother's blood can we
predict the gestational age of pregnancy
so in other words can we how accurate
can we be in in determining the
gestational age of pregnancy by looking
at monadic alot of patients in the
maternal blood so to do this study we
recruited 28 women and separated them in
two cohort a training cohort where we
could build a model that Nemo will be
talking to us about and then a
validation cohort of which sent of whose
samples were kept in the fridge didn't
touch them and then that was used to
prospectively validate the results of
this study now these women were followed
longitudinally during pregnancy and then
six weeks postpartum and PP means
postpartum and we collected samples
three time points during pregnancy and
allyce them with cyclops importantly
there is a certain variability
associated with the time of sending for
each one of these samples and we use
this this variability to build to build
a continuous variable onto which we can
build a multivariate model I will
predict the timing of sampling or the
gesture the gestational age at the time
of sampling and this is what we call the
union clock
I want to show two slides here that are
technical too to explain to you in a
little bit more details what kind of
measurements we're doing first of all
all these measurements are done in whole
blood samples and we're used as this
month to a system in order to collect
and fix whole blood right after fiblets
lobotomy which allows us to really
comprehensive lis look at every immune
cell pressuring these blood samples and
then I want to introduce you to the type
of data set that we are that we will be
analyzing so using I think it's a 43
parameter my cytometry assay we're able
to precisely characterize about 25 cell
types from your innate immune cells on
top to your adaptive immune cells at the
bottom so the yellow dots here are
representing the frequency of each one
of these cell subsets but at the same
time we use 10 intracellular markers to
look at the functional responses of
these immune cells along the line of
very canonical and important signaling
pathways that TLR pathways enough
capably pathways and in the various
objects that signaling pathways now we
look at these signaling responses again
at baseline in the endogenous way this
is how immune cells are responding to
the over to the environment of pregnancy
those are the purple dusts but we're
also looking at them in response to
stimulation with receptor specific
ligands so the blue turquoise dots
represent the response to LPS
we also measured the response to nature
Lucan cocktail containing out two four
six and their response to interferon
alpha
all right thanks briefs we can talk a
little bit about how we can take this
data set and build those models that
predict gestational age the first thing
that we observed in in this graph was
that the data is
actually very modular this is consistent
with what we already know about the
immune system that multiple signaling
pathways from multiple cell types
correlate closely with each other and
you can see them in forms of these tight
correlation modules in this graph so
when building a model that would make
predictions we would have to take that
into account so our multivariate models
are fairly simple we have Y or vector of
gestational age and we have X matrix
that that graph that we just showed you
and our task is to find a transformation
that minimizes the error of between
predicted gestational age and actual
gestational age that second term to the
right of the equation is basic basically
making sure that the model remains
constraint that the model doesn't get
too big we can make the model even more
simplified by using a l1 norm instead of
an album l2 norm what that does is that
it it simplifies the model to use only
the measurements that are absolutely
necessary for making a prediction that
is important because when trying to
understand the biology of these models
we don't want to look at a model that's
overly complicated for a human to
understand and also when you take these
models to a resource-poor setting or to
a regulatory setting it would be a lot
easier to use them although that has
fewer measurements and finally we
combined these two ideas interesting
your model that uses both an l1 add an
l2 nor to find models that are simple
yet they capture those tightly
correlated modules so people wouldn't
pick only one representative from each
module they would capture the entire
module if the entire module is is
correlated with gestational age another
another idea that be incorporated into
these models was the idea of
incorporating
background biological knowledge in the
form of Bayesian priors to be able to
make more accurate predictions what we
did is that we basically went to the
existing literature on immunology and
figured out which signaling pathways in
which cell types are supposed to respond
to which simulations this was done
entirely without any knowledge of the
pregnancy this is just about our general
knowledge of how we think they mean
system works and then we provided this
information to that in the form of
Bayesian priors in a high dimensional
data set like this one there usually are
many many models that have a similar
predictive power they are all able to
predict in this case gestational age
with a similar error rate what this
patient prior does is that it encourages
the model to find the instances that are
more consistent with our current
understanding of immunology we
originally did this to to make it easier
for us to trust the data to make it
easier for us to to just understand the
biology that we're looking for but we
were pleasantly surprised to see that it
actually all performed a standard
machine learning algorithms that didn't
have access to this prior knowledge on
the y-axis we have minus log 10 of
p-value for correlation gestational age
so the larger bars represent algorithms
that are more accurate the first bar is
are optimized elastic net that has this
prior knowledge and the rest are
standard predictive algorithms on top we
have our original cord and on the bottom
we have our validation or blinded
validation court a doctor had never seen
before originally all these algorithms
were doing really well but on the bottom
when we look at our validation cohort
only the model that has this prior
knowledge incorporated remains a
statistically significant after one from
an adjustment for for multiple
hypotheses
so this this was published just a few
months ago in science immunology on the
left again we have we have our training
cohort and on the right we have the same
model applied to postpartum samples
after the dashed line you can see that
the immune system has starts to
gradually recover and yet to get closer
to a non-pregnant estate a few weeks
after delivery we can go back to that
correlation graph that we showed you and
highlight the nodes that are
particularly going up or going down
during pregnancy larger nodes here you
present nodes that on a single eyelid
level by themselves are highly
correlated with gestational age the
smaller nodes are nodes that are not as
correlated with gestational age the
colors represent their coefficients from
our multivariate model the red ones are
highly associated positively with
gestational age and the blue ones are
negatively associated the briefs can now
tell you a little bit about the biology
of of these findings and how they can
guide future future
biological investigations yeah and
what's interesting in this
representation of these immune features
overlaid on the overall immune networks
is that we realize that there they
belong to various communities features
that can be characterized based on their
most important attributes and this can
be a cell type or signaling pathways and
really what this is doing is it's
pointing us in the direction of how the
various ideological compartments are
experiencing of pregnancy now the
important communities were pointing us
into the direction and K cell changes
dendritic cell changes granule site
changes as well as adaptive as well
adapted responses particularly in naive
t-cells now we
currently some of these risk some of
these features are very consistent with
what is known the immune response to to
pregnancy and others a direction of
interesting hypothesis so I want to show
you now the most important or most
predictive features of their model and
that's important because it will guide
future studies and the development of
new mastectomy tree panels to ongoing
and future studies the number one
feature is in pink here belongs to the
community of features in pink and it was
pointing at this phosphorylation of
their transcription of the transcription
factor stat5
in naive cd4 t-cell and you see that it
progressively increases during pregnancy
two levels are much higher than in the
public postpartum state now as you may
know stat5
plays multiple function in the
differentiation of of cd4 T cells but
downstream of il-2 one of the most
important role of stat5 is to guide the
differentiation of cd4 T cells to the
peripheral T right or to the T ragged
cell type particularly the peripheral to
rank cell subset and so it promotes the
differentiation of peripheral T regs and
their stability now that's obviously
very important and very reassuring
we know from Alex Ruebens Keyes lab and
instancing waste lab how important T
regs are in the maintenance of of
freedom internal tolerance during
pregnancy and how from animal models how
did this dysregulation of this of this
of the cell types is leads to premature
birth and the loss of feeder maternal
tolerance the other feature was pointing
us in a totally different compartment of
the immune system it was pointing us to
the direction of innate immune responses
and so here in the the red dot in the
orange community were all where
is communities of Union features that
were pointing at the Dalek receptor for
response to LPS in innate immune sense
in innate immune cells and the red dot
is the future in dendritic cells myeloid
dendritic cells and what we're learning
here is that the NF kappa-b response to
LPS is dampened or originally at the
beginning of pregnancy and progressively
increases during pregnancy and that's
also interesting because we know mostly
from animal models from Sylvain chef
Shem Tov's group in the University of
Montreal that the response to TL are an
innate immune cells in pregnancy which
is associated with the activation of the
inflammasome pathway is very much
implicated in the maintenance of
pregnancy we also know from a recent
paper by Ramirez group that inflammation
activation is the employment of pathways
activated and the onset of labor and is
and is is functional with the onset of
premature labor all right so moving on
to the second part of the talk what is a
special about this mass psychology
platform that we are using is that it's
looking at individual cells that's
that's a very powerful thing to do
because cells are the smallest
functioning units of life and you can
you can actually figure out how to
modulate them it interacts with our
microbiome with what happens at a
transcript on a stove wall at a
proteomics level as well as the helical
context that these patients are in we
wanted to understand the immune system
in this larger picture in the same
cohort we produced a larger data set we
have cell free RNA from the quake lab at
the Stanford we have a personal
proteomics I say that we produce
together with marking and priests
we have metabolomics analysis of the
same cohort by the Schneider laughs the
master geometry data said that we just
showed you as well as fairly extensive
microbiome profiling and analysis of
asthma and serum all done here at a
Stanford and of course this is done in
collaboration with a large bar
informatics team most importantly side
job over there you know in a red shirt
it much of this workout I will be
talking about here our first goal was to
understand if these data sets can can
interact together interact with each
other and make better predictions of
gestational age if you simply put all of
these measurements into a correlation
network you are not going to see a whole
lot simply because there are too many
connections to many correlations so we
use the similar again here boy is
gestational age X is the full data and
we try to do the exact same thing we try
to build an elastic net that predicts
gestational age first we leave that on
one data set at a time so each of these
bars represent an elastic net built on
each data set y axis is a gain minus log
10 of p value you can see that some some
of these data sets are better correlated
with gestational age than others for
example on top the microbiome data set
doesn't move that much we already knew
that the microbiome is fairly stable
throughout pregnancy and on the bottom
the proteomic stages that has a pretty
good correlation with gestational age we
can look at that on our test set and we
will see that it generalizes fairly well
to previously unseen samples we can also
apply diagram samples towards the right
of the graph these artists if these are
the samples 12 pregnancy that have been
used for building your model and then
you can apply them to the postpartum
samples you can see that most of them to
start progressing towards a non-pregnant
estate but some for examples that we are
na
as a higher quote-unquote memory level
it takes it longer to recover back to
baseline now if we take these models and
combine them together and look at the
look at the final outcome this is the
correlation graph the graph mostly
consists of measurements from cell free
RNA and microbiome this was a little bit
surprising to us but it turns out that
that's happening because these datasets
have a significantly larger number of
measurements they are completely
overwhelming the predictive model so we
have to go back to our equations and add
an extra term down here that would
penalize the datasets that are producing
a larger number of measurements that
helps improve our predictive over a
little bit as seen in the gray bar here
but that was that wasn't enough another
issue was that some of the larger
datasets may actually have less
information in that this is a large data
set that only has three major clusters
maybe four and then this is a smaller
data set that has many many clusters so
from an information theory point of view
potentially it's measuring global
ecology Occident has more information
content we quantified that by by using
PCA on the left you have the number of
measurements in each essay on the right
we have the number of principal
components that it takes black holes for
90% variance you can see that the master
geometry essay for example has a very
high level of modality even though it
doesn't have as many measurements
compared to cell-free RNA or microbiome
so we had to modify our strategy to
account for this what we ended up doing
is called a stack generalization you
basically build a model on each data set
first and then you take the predictions
of gestational age from each model and
use it as an input for your for your
final predictions you are stacking the
predictions of each individual data set
on top
each other and then you build an
additional model that makes a prediction
based on all of those results combined
and that gives us this black bar here
that is even more accurate than before
and generalizes to test site we can then
ask if these models can be reduced to a
limited number of features that can then
be biologically investigated here we are
starting on 200 features on the x-axis
and we gradually reduce them until we
hit a point that we can no longer reduce
them without losing the our predictive
power and that gives us this correlation
at work of the features that are
predicted from each data set we can then
annotate the network using what we
understand from the biology of these
features on the top we have our
microbiome data set here we have our
proteomics data set CSH one ch2 has
already been reported in the literature
to correlate with gestational age it's
right next to CS h one at a
transcriptomics level we also have a
number of metabolic SIDS that that we
don't have time to go to and our master
geometry features are done here right
next to the proteomics measurements
breeze can tell you more about this
specific interaction so as you notice
the most predictive feature of our
immune clock model that phosphorylation
of stat 5 and 8 for T cells also appear
in the multi linear integrated model
that Nemo just showed you
eglee associated with CHS one of
so-called human placenta elective gen
which appeared in the programming
dataset as well in this selfie our new
data set so we wanted to evaluate this
the nature of this interaction a little
bit further here is the roaming data set
that is represented again as a
correlation network and what we noticed
was that CHS want belong to a cluster of
the music of programming features in red
year that were all related functionally
by the fact that they could activate the
jacks tag signaling pathway in
particularly three of those we're
related to the objects that five
signaling pathway and those included
pro-life prolactin CH s1 and il-2 for
like tenancy AG says SmartConnect
can activate the jacks that five
pathways through the collecting receptor
and il-2 downstream of the il-2 receptor
however when we stimulated whole blood
samples from women pregnant women at
different times in pregnancy when these
various ligands or combination of these
ligands what we noticed was that in our
hands only il-2 could lead to a robust
relations of stat5 in 1940 cells so now
evidence of absence or absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence but
perhaps what is happening is that the
interaction between CH s1 and the step 5
feature is indirectly mediated by the
tight correlation that we're observing
between the il-2 concentration in plasma
from women collected at the same time as
we're going to set up data so the L 2 is
increasing during pregnancy and tightly
correlates with stuff like immune cell
feature and biologically again this is
this is reasonable and it's pointing at
the il-2 mediated differentiation of set
of cd4 T cells and 2:30 rag population
for example we know that cornellà plays
an important role in some preterm births
we can go back to our data set and find
gardnerella in the microbiome data set
and then ask can I use all these other
data sets psych up data set the
proteomics data set and so on to find
surrogate measurements for gardnerella
you can basically do the exact same
thing except that you are excluding the
microbiome data set now and you're
replacing gestational age with levels of
gardener in your predictive model this
is what we got when we tried to build a
model on one day just at a time what was
really interesting here on poor training
and tested is that the data set that
used to do really well is not doing as
well and the data sets that were not
doing as well in the past are doing
pretty well here so it's important to
not make general statements about one
platform being better than another it's
just at one platform maybe more relevant
for for one a specific biological task
when we combined the data sets again the
model that accounted for both modularity
and size did a lot better than simply
accounting for size without accounting
for modularity we can also look at the
correlation network like before we can
reduce the model to the number of
measurements that are necessary and then
we can put them in a correlation network
and ant annotate or annotate the parts
that we understand the biology of we
won't go into the details of this
network I will just point to the largest
most important feature from our master
geometry panel TCR gamma delta T cells
which are known to be important in
mucosal immunity so we are excited to
see them especially when we are looking
at at the interaction with big
microbiome and gardener obviously
something that we need to further
investigate in the future in terms of
future direction
for for the informatics part of the talk
obviously or about part of the study we
are very interested in looking at larger
and more diverse data sets that have a
significant number of preterm births we
are working with several other
collaborators to to expand our efforts
into larger data sets from the
developing world particularly in terms
of the plan for Mattox analysis of these
data sets we are very interested in
multi objective optimization as well
especially for low resource settings
here on the y-axis again we have minus
10 of p-value in the first bar we have
the full model that we've been talking
about for gestational age in the second
bar I'm excluding our most important
data set the orange one and what you can
see is that the model can reach in
itself to compensate for some of the
loss print so these other data sets can
be combined in various ways to
compensate for a missing data set this
helps us answer more complex questions
in a resourceful setting when we have to
pick and choose between data sets we can
ask which combination of these data sets
gives us the most predictive power for
example or dollar so we have cost and we
have predictive power or it can have
even more objectives it can have cost or
feasible sampling from from a particular
site is and predictive power all these
objectives in the future will need to be
optimized at the same time in terms of
detecting deviation from normal that the
statistics of it is not actually build
especially when you have limited time
points that's another area that we are
working on we are also very interested
in integrating these assets with
population level information generally
these kind of multi-omics analysis is
very expensive and it's not feasible to
to
I say an entire population what we are
trying to do is to approach this from
the other end here we have a data set of
1.5 million birds in California each dot
represents a cost of patients you can
see that there are a specific clusters
that have a higher black to white ratio
we generally know that African Americans
have a higher preterm birth right so the
idea here is to objectively select the
samples from these from an analysis like
this that would represent the entire
population and then go back into a
detailed multi-omics profiling on them
and then that would enable us to
generalize the results to the entire
population and finally our last
interesting project is to integrate our
findings with killing a call phenotypes
normally here we are only looking at
preterm birth versus no preterm birth
but there are more complicated
phenotypes that we have access to this
is a correlation network of all the
demographic information that we could
get from our Stanford cohort we can then
use this correlation network as a
backbone I'm going to change its color
to black and there is the backbone down
there and you can project your entire
multi-omics partner biological data set
on top of that killing the core backbone
to simultaneously understand for example
the impact of stress on various
biological modalities and on pregnancy
itself alright and then let me finish up
with our rest of the future directions
that are pertinent to the immunology
side of things and psychometry side of
things what we've shown you with our
previous study is the model that
predicted the gestation in obviously the
the next question that's very important
clinically is to determine
whether we can predict the onset of
labor or identify immuno this
ideological switch that may be
associated with the transition from non
labouring women to labouring women
Confederation / tuition so we couldn't
do this with with a previous data set
because although all delivered at term
some of them had c-sections some of them
were induced and so it wasn't a
spontaneous onset of labor dataset and
over the last year two postdocs in the
lab Kaz and Chauhan have worked
tremendously hard to recruit over a
hundred women that delivered between
last February and February of those over
50 women that delivers spontaneously at
term and so this creates a very
beautiful data set of samples are
collected during pregnancy with an
emphasis an emphasis towards the end of
pregnancy towards a third trimester and
that will allow us to to identify immune
events that perhaps predict the onset of
labor but of course you know working on
on our work on term labor is part of our
homework our major focus is to determine
whether the immune clock of pregnancy is
disrupted in pathology or pregnancy as
the immune clock accelerated for example
in the context of preterm births and to
do this we have to expand our work and
collaborate with other centers because
the incidents of preterm births is 10 to
12 percent and so in order to validate
our findings prospectively
we need access to larger cohorts of
patients I want to show you before going
into into the details of the these
collaborations I want to show you a very
preliminary data in the different
context of pathological pregnancy in the
context of
severe preeclampsia this is exciting
because it is perhaps speaking to the
fact that with the approach that we took
we are we are oriented towards
biological phenomenon that may be
implicated in pathogenesis of abnormal
pregnancies so again coming back to this
this feature of our immune clock model
the stat 5 feature I want to show you
the very preliminary data of a study
that show you on LED comparing two
groups of women during pregnancy a
control a group that delivered normally
at term and then that suffered from
severe preeclampsia and you can see that
in this very very first pass of the
analysis just looking at this one
immunity feature you know 10 out of 12
or 911 control patients show that their
stat5 feature is increasing during
pregnancy here we're comparing a blood
sample of the second trimester to blood
sample drawn in the first trimester so
expectedly we see this increase instead
of ivory sponsoring pregnancy in the
control women but virtually all but two
of the women that suffer from severe
preeclampsia has a completely different
response in their status five response
is going down during pregnancy so now
this is a univariate analysis where the
data look fairly strong and we're
certainly expecting that with a
multivariate elastic net model we'll be
able to separate very significantly
these two but finishing up on the idea
of using a similar approach to to
understand the immunological
abnormalities that may be associated or
perhaps driving preterm labor we were
fortunate to be implicated in a large
collaboration with yamani group and this
is a project that was fun that is funded
by the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
the amani group is a large consortium of
various sites in Bangladesh Pakistan in
Tanzania and they have an incredible
capacity to recruit women during
pregnancy and collect quality samples or
various omics analyses to give you an
idea of the merit of this capacity our
collaboration started in early 2017 and
in less than a year those three
different sites collected samples
through pregnancy in over 500 women that
delivered this year of which 48 a
delivered creature so we're really
hopeful that with this kind of
collaboration we'll be able to generate
a large sample large enough sample size
to really be able to to get to this
question of communal deviations
associated with preterm birth and
validating them prospectively I want to
finish up by showing you that we were
and this is not an easy task but we're
able to send samples back and forth to
send them smart tubes and they sent us a
sample back to Stanford and we started
doing the QC of this data and so far so
good we're able to show that the samples
can be stimulated and we're getting the
expected responses in these samples
collected in this regard in this example
in Bangladesh so these are very exciting
prospects and obviously all this work
can can be done without the hard work
and intelligence of many students and
postdocs in our labs the top in the top
pictures are our people that were
implicated in the mass spectometry
generating and analyzing the cytometry
data set so a mean sigh again yo show
you on Kaz and Yanni and then the bottom
pictures are about the people that are
doing all the powerful analysis of
bioinformatics analysis at the unit
Ananda and not
seiyya Tony Tony and then Martin eggs
that I mentioned earlier in our in our
presentation and this is our
acknowledgments slide on a finish by
thanking our sponsors the March of Dimes
and the Gates Foundation the chri at
Stanford as well as the Canadian
Institute and then you know major
collaborators in this in this project
obviously in the market I'm Center where
we are deeply involved in in discussions
of our work and other people work and
this is led by David Stevenson and Gary
Shaw and all the others here that are
listed Gary Nolan is always there to
provide mentorship throughout our
experience as junior faculties at
Stanford Rockton shirani and Trevor
Hestia have been extremely extremely
helpful in development of the elastic
net algorithm that Nima developed as
well as our other collaborators for the
floor for sharing their multi-omics
datasets thank you thank you and I will
point out that I did not develop the
elastic net algorithm we humbly use it
Thank You dr. Gutierrez dr. Agia pour
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
our webinar if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question drop-down
box located in the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
now let's get started our first question
is you use some math cytometry to define
the immune clock of pregnancy in
peripheral blood what are the local
immune mechanisms and the Phaedo
maternal interface well thanks thanks
for asking this question it's obviously
a very important question what we're
doing with
with Masato meetry as well as other
omics platform is we're looking at the
at the peripheral immune system or
maternal blood in general and so
obviously the the action are the if you
want to say another way the epicenter of
these various pacemakers of pregnancy is
the fetus itself and the placenta and so
they're clearly really important
mechanisms are happening locally that
that likely drives these these logical
response and what we are measuring in a
verbal that our signatures of these
response whether they're positive or a
consequence of these these response we
don't know and so in order to get to
this to this to this question we have
recently engaged in a in a collaboration
with the University of Chicago with
Carol over then she has started using
mass otama tree to analyze the immune
landscape or the sailer landscape
actually of the placenta using both the
maternal side and the pendent fetal side
of the placenta at pregnant at the time
of delivery and in a study that we're
doing together now we're gonna be able
to look at the same time at least birth
of the peripheral immune response as
well as the central immune response and
that will allows us to that will allow
us to into an integrative analysis and
see and there's a meaning there are
meaningful correlations between the two
datasets and hopefully learn from learn
about the biology that is coming from
these local mechanisms and our have
these ripple effect in in the peripheral
thank you our next question now
cytometry dramatically increases the
number of cell types and signaling path
that can be measured how do you control
for false positives all right I can I
can take that one when the number of
measurements increase at the level that
are increasing in the cytometry field
and especially with my cytometry the
traditional statistical answer is that
you have to increase your cohort size
when you have a larger cohort or when
you have independent cohorts you can
naturally control for false positives
but that is not always possible
obviously
so the alternatives are C or D uses
sparse models that reduce the complexity
of the models to very few measurements
when you have fewer measurements
involved in the final predictive model
the chances of false positives also
reduce and finally the thing that we are
very excited about is the idea of
incorporating background biological
knowledge into the models so that a
sparse af-- ocation process can be
guided or our current understanding of
the immune system if there are specific
features that we know are robust because
there have been tens of articles already
published about them when we have a
large number of measurements those
features should have to be prioritized
if everything else is equal so we are
building on decades of immunological
knowledge to to to populate our high
dimensional space to account for that
sparsity for that lack of large large
large number of observations thank you
our next question what are the biggest
considerations for incorporating Mathai
cometary data into future logs
large-scale omics studies cytometry is
unique in that it increases the number
of simultaneous measurements in various
cell types but it also
produce an extremely high number of
measurements like we would get from
sequencing assays so we have to balance
out the number of measurements versus
the amount of information that is
provided there are multiple ways to do
that we talked about one of them here
but generally low dimensional assays
like blooming eggs like the are the tend
to higher information content because
they are measuring specific biological
processes that we understand very well
as dimensionality increases we can
measure for example gene expressions of
a large number of genes that all belong
to the same pathway and are highly
correlated in math psychometric falls
somewhere between those two extremes we
have to make sure that that the pipeline
that we use does a good job at capturing
that trade-off between number of
measurements and information content the
second thing that I like to point out is
that they missing values or are an
important thing to deal with normally in
most essays when you have missing values
it simply means that your assay has
failed for that particular sample or you
just couldn't even collect a sample in
the first place but for cytometry
accounting for missing boxes is a little
bit more nuanced because for example if
you're looking at median of a specific
signaling pathway in a cell type and a
patient happens to just not have that
cell type not have any cells in that
cell type what do you do with the median
do you set it to zero do you use a
predictive algorithm to interpolate the
missing value but that's another more
nuanced thing to think about when trying
to integrate math cytometry with other
omics data sets thank you and it looks
like we have time for one final question
what are the advantages of using a whole
wide math cytometry assay so yeah most
studies are or using cold blood and I'll
I'll give you the advantages and also
the drawbacks and I'll start with the
drawbacks Soho block versus PB and see
obviously the whole blood system the
cells are fixed and banked fixed and you
can you can revive them and analyze them
as life cells as you would do with PBMC
samples that's a that's a that's you
know that's a limitation however they're
in our hands very important identity so
number one you'll have access to the
entire immune system neutrophils in
particular and all their subsets are
accessible from lettuce and you with
them with PBMC maybe more importantly
what we're these exploratory studies
that that we are doing where the biology
is very much novel and and hasn't been
explored as much in humans as in any
other diseases like cancer you would say
it's really important for us to generate
these initial data sets with a biology
that is relevant to what is happening in
Evo and is as close to endogenous
changes and dodging is functional
responses that are actually happening in
the human blood and with a whole blood
assay you you have the ability to really
fix these functional response within
minutes of phlebotomy within minutes of
blood draws and really be close to what
is happening in vivo but with minimal
perturbation of your of your sample
beyond stimulating with with for 15
minutes for example and then lastly and
this is very pertinent to the type of
global collaborations that we have now
is the feasibility and the the fact that
that the system that we're using this
cartridge system is very exportable when
we had to determine what assay to use
that we can standardized
replicate fairly you know to the letter
the essay that we're using here at
Stanford replicated that in Bangladesh
in Tanzania for example we wanted
something that's very robust and helium
implementable and so here there is four
simple steps when if we want to
stimulate cells as we do and as we're
doing in Bangladesh we can use tubes
that have lyophilized stimulations and
so it's exactly the same process whether
it's the cell or stimulator or not it's
not extra burden and all this is very
much standardized and and and you know I
want to emphasize this part that the
ability to collect quality samples in
many patients and in remote location is
really paramount and you know this is
you know this that the quality of the
data set in the end it's it's something
that sometimes is overlooked and we
think that with doing a whole blood
assay we can really have this high
quality generated data set of very high
quality I'd like to once again thank dr.
brings to the air and doctors you poor
for their presentation I would also like
to thank elaborate for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June 2018 you
will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
so I made who may have missed today's
live events that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon bye